Dameon asks when you have a billion
dollar potential business plan without
the financial resources in the inventory
where do you start with funding Damien
you know this is one of those questions
that I like picking for the show because
I'm always scared to be too rude to the
audience you guys are smiling okay
now I'm freaked out that eight times
doing stuff just oh you guys are worried
about how much I'm about to thrash
Damien got it
Damien the the answer to that question
is very simple like we are in a bubble
of financing right now there are people
that would finance this venture just an
idea it's happened people come in with a
deck they have nothing people give them
money for a piece of the business and
they go and do it that's your only
option I mean there's nothing else
practical I mean you know anytime
somebody sets up a question of the
amount of time do many people have
emailed me with the title about to help
you buy the New York Jets or Gary open
this email and you will buy the New York
Jets or I'm gonna help you buy the New
York Jets and next line is hey Gary the
fan of your work
I have a billion dollar idea ideas are
everybody's got an idea Steve you have
ideas all sorts of ideas I mean I have
unlimited ideas you know if you if you
have the idea that's nice if you don't
have the dollars and if you don't have
the inventory well you might find to
have nothing and so the only way you do
something about that is go and get
dollars from somebody - I assume get the
inventory and I don't understand what
the inventory is in this exact question
but the reason I'm answering this
question is for the entire vaynernation
to to understand that practicality
matters right passion which I'm loaded
with is great right ideas transcend the
word world
great agreed but in execution in
practicality is when these things become
true that's what matters
that's what the people we all look up to
have done they've taken from here and
they've made it happen
and so that is massively important and
that is something I push all of you to
start spending some
time on